no the world does not come to an end the
world is just going to go chela and I'm
trying to be part of society hey guys my
name is grace Helbig if you did not know
now you know welcome to my after-school
special this is my gang sign music
festival season is upon us it's just
when all the clearance from Halloween
gets a huge second chance I've been to a
music festival or two in my day
literally only two I've been to two
music festivals so I know what I'm
talking about
two is enough people have two kids and I
talk like they know how to have all kids
they do who am I to judge so I've
created a list of seven Coachella
essentials but these work for any music
festival that you're going to because
spoiler alert guitar unique quirky let's
get into it the first thing you need are
cute sunglasses these are essential
because most music festivals if not all
music festivals take place outside so
you need to protect your eyes against
the Sun I recommend getting a cheap pair
of sunglasses because it's super easy to
lose them up music festivals and cheaper
sunglasses are easier to break apart and
turn into a series of shifts that you
can use as weapons to protect yourself
next on the list is sunscreen you're
going to be in extreme direct sunlight
so you want to protect your skin also
sunscreen is slightly edible if you find
yourself in a situation in which you
need to eat it to survive and there's
lots of varieties they all taste the
same like snacks cute and comfortable
closed toed shoes yes you might want to
wear those really cute but really
uncomfortable open-toed gladiator
sandals but the walk to the main music
fairgrounds is a lot longer in dustier
than you realize the walk is also a lot
longer and dustier than you realize when
the earth as you know it has been
destroyed and you have no actual home
and you're just trying to find a safe
place how far away that will be you
don't know so invest in some cute
clothes to shoes or lightweight boots
they'll also help you protect your
toenail so that you can eventually use
them as currency if need be
next a cute backpack you want to make
sure that you have a bag that's big
enough for all the things that you might
need throughout the day
your stabby sunglasses extra pair of
clothes to choose protect your toenail
currency eccentric cetera cetera the
list goes on
also backpacks are great because they
keep your hands-free so you can dance as
much as you want to and you can also
fight for your life if you need to next
a bandana music festivals are so much
dustier than you think especially
Coachella
so bandanas can protect you from the
dust can protect your neck from the Sun
and align you with the appropriate gang
when your only key to survival is
choosing the right side and the last
thing you'll need for Coachella or any
music festival is a fake tan I use the
st. Tropez self tan express I love it it
doesn't streak it's easy to apply it
doesn't get all over everything
it's wonderful to give you a natural tan
a natural glow the color also blends
into dirt like perfectly so if you need
to like strip down naked and lay face
down in the dirt as it means to
camouflage yourself so that you're not
murdered this is the perfect product for
you so there you go there are my seven
essentials that every person needs for
Coachella or any music festival I hope
these were helpful let me know which is
your favorite or which else I should
have included in this list and I'll see
you guys at Coachella like I won't be
there oh what's over I don't know
okay I have been watching a lot of The
Walking Dead and it is very likely that
I got coachella confused with the
walking dead but I don't see much of a
difference a lot of dust covered people
doing this and just all sort of looking
at each other like should we just get
ourselves I'm kidding
The Walking Dead looks like a much
better time